SIERRA: The global arms trade doesn’t enjoy
a particularly sunny reputation.
And honestly, fair.
Groups like Amnesty International have condemned
the industry for its lack of oversight, noting
the deadly cost paid by civilians.
The United States is the biggest arms dealer
on earth.
From 2017 to 2021 it sold weapons to over
100 nations, and in 2020 alone, American companies
made $111 billion from foreign military sales.
While this may sound like a lot, profits are
actually only a part of why the U.S. does
it.
Behind the scenes, arms sales are a common
foreign policy tool, giving the U.S. leverage
over the countries it sells to, and, according
to some, helping it to shape behavior, conflicts,
and security all over the world.
Take our involvement in the Ukraine conflict.
By sending billions of dollars in weapons,
along with intelligence and training, the
U.S. was able to provide crucial support to
Ukraine as it pushed back against invading
Russian forces.
All without risking a single U.S. soldier
on the battlefield.
But it isn’t always so clear-cut.
In Yemen, Saudi Arabia has used American weapons
to commit human rights abuses as part of a
war the United States has opposed.
In the Afghanistan war, American soldiers
faced enemies using weapons first provided
by the U.S. to anti-Soviet mujahideen decades
before.
This is a complex, and messy business.
I’m Gabrielle Sierra, and this is Why It
Matters.
Today, the reality behind U.S. dominance in
the global arms trade.
David D. Eisenhower: Good evening my fellow
Americans, until the latest of our world conflicts,
the United States had no armaments industry.
But we can no longer risk emergency improvisation
of national defense.
We have been compelled to create a permanent
armaments industry of vast proportions.
Joseph Biden Jr.: Last week I signed an 800
million dollar package of security assistance
to Ukraine.
Today, I’m announcing another 800 million
dollars to further augment Ukraine’s ability
to fight in the East.
Donald J. Trump: If we don’t sell it to
‘em, they’ll say ‘well, thank you very
much, we’ll buy it from Russia’ or ‘thank
you very much, we’ll buy it from China.’
Barack Obama: I can also announce that the
United States is fully lifting the ban on
the sale of military equipment to Vietnam
that has been in place for some 50 years.
Gabrielle SIERRA: If I'm someone who comes
in knowing nothing about arms trade, which
I have a feeling many of us might be in that
camp, do you think you can give me just a
sort of 101 rundown?
What are the key things that I should know?
Rachel STOHL: We don't often think about the
arms trade when we're reading news stories
or hearing about current events in the news,
but it's sort of front and center in the tools
that are used by Washington in its foreign
policy arsenal.
SIERRA: This is Rachel Stohl.
She is the vice president of research programs
at the Stimson Center, where she also directs
their conventional defense program.
STOHL: The global arms trade is an integral
part of governments and their foreign policy
and defense policies around the world.
The United States commands by far the largest
share of the arms market.
It's more than 40% of the global arms trade
just in the last year alone, and that's next
to twice the size of its closest global competitor.
So really they're unrivaled and unparalleled
in their domination of the arms market.
Bill HARTUNG: There's a handful of supplier
nations that control the bulk of the trade
in major weapons - tanks, aircraft, helicopters,
missiles, et cetera.
SIERRA: This is Bill Hartung.
He is a senior research fellow at the Quincy
Institute for Responsible Statecraft, he focuses
on among other topics, global arms trade,
military strategy and nuclear policy.
HARTUNG: And the United States is at the top
of the list.
Russia is about half of that.
China's about one seventh.
France is a player.
UK and Germany are in the mix.
But basically the top five control three quarters
of the trade.
So when you've got this big military complex,
there's an incentive to export because it
makes bigger production lines cheaper per
weapon.
It's very profitable for companies to sell
overseas when the government has already paid
for them to develop the weapons.
SIERRA: One reason U.S. foreign arms sales
lead the pack is that the U.S. spends an extraordinary
amount on its military overall.
Defense spending hit $801 billion in 2021
alone.
Compare that to the next highest spender,
China, at $293 billion.
The US is also home to 4 of the top 5 private
arms manufacturers in the world.
Companies like Lockheed Martin, Boeing, Northrup
Grumman, and Raytheon Technologies are synonymous
with the business of war.
It's a bit like silicon valley - where American
companies tower over a global industry.
So how did the U.S. get here?
Well, after WWII, the U.S. arms industry grew
rapidly throughout the Cold War.
The United States was spooked about Soviet
expansion and increased its military budget
as a result.
Preferring proxy conflicts to outright war,
the U.S. and Russia increasingly shipped weapons
to smaller nations.
Budgets had grown so much that by 1960, President
Eisenhower warned of a booming "military industrial
complex", leading to decades of debate about
how much the arms trade, and private arms
industry, fuels conflict.
SIERRA: How does the arms industry compare
to other large scale industries, like agriculture
or oil?
STOHL: Sure.
So if we compare the arms trade to other industries,
the international defense trade remains relatively
small, but that's in terms of dollar value.
So if you look at the Stockholm International
Peace Research Institute or SIPRI, they put
the value of the arms trade around $212 billion
in 2019.
Now, if you compared that to the global trade
in agriculture, that was approximately $1.4
trillion dollars in 2020.
SIERRA: Okay, because yeah, that sounded like
a big number to me, but definitely not in
comparison.
Okay.
STOHL: So that gives you sort of a sense of
the enterprise.
But I don't want people to be too bogged down
in sort of the numbers and the dollar value
because when you're thinking about the impact
of the global arms trade, it's really vast,
right?
It involves or impacts nearly every country
on the planet, whether they're arms exporters,
arms importers, maybe they're a transit or
a trans shipment country, maybe they feel
the effects of the arms trade in terms of,
like, refugee flows, or maybe they're involved
in conflict or neighboring conflict.
So there are many different downstream consequences.
Now, obviously, we don't intend for innocent
civilians to be killed by the global arms
trade, but it happens.
And so we have to think about how the arms
trade fits into larger policy concerns.
SIERRA: Right?
These are weapons or tools that can lead to
death and destruction.
STOHL: Deadly consequences all across the
board.
SIERRA: Is there a spectrum of relationships
from a full on adversary like Iran, to whom
we would never sell weapons to an ally like
Ukraine, to whom we provide weapons for free,
to a NATO ally like the United Kingdom, who
we are committed to defend, you know, unconditionally
from attack?
Where do arms deals fall on such a spectrum?
HARTUNG: The idea of a spectrum is a good
one because as mentioned, countries like Iran
or Syria, the United States is never going
to sell them weapons unless there's a dramatic
political earthquake of some sort.
In Ukraine, it's of the moment, the weapons
are vital for it to defend itself.
A country like the UK or another NATO ally
there is a commitment to defend them and therefore,
sales to those countries are relatively uncontroversial.
Although they're an advanced economy, so they
pay for the weapons, they don't get them as
aid.
And then there's a big group in the middle,
some African allies, some Middle Eastern allies
and others where there's human rights issues,
maybe there's been a military coup or there's
active conflicts.
So in all of those cases, there's judgment
calls to be made.
There's no automatic decision to make the
sale.
There may be conditions.
You may withhold weapons at a certain point
if conflict is heating up and you don't want
to stoke it.
So it ranges from countries that the sales
are uncontroversial, in some cases urgent,
in some cases for future deterrence, then
you've got this problematic group, and then
you've got a group that's completely beyond
the pale because they're long standing adversaries.
SIERRA: To get just like a little more granular,
step by step, how do these agreements start,
who is approving them?
How long does it take?
How does it go?
STOHL: I think at the most basic level, what
we can say is the U.S. engages and arms transfers
under several headings.
So the first is government to government sales,
also known as foreign military sales in which
the U.S. government sells directly to another
government.
And those are overseen by the Department of
Defense with inter agency feedback about those
particular sales.
SIERRA: Direct foreign military sales happen
all the time and it’s the one we hear about
most.
This October, for example, the US sold missiles
to Japan, to the tune of $450 million.
These types of decisions, and arms sales policy
in general, are made at the executive level.
Presidents have significant leeway to shape
them.
But with direct foreign military sales there
is also a complicated review process.
It includes the embassy, the combatant commander
of a particular region, the Defense Security
Cooperation Agency, Secretaries of State,
Defense, Commerce, and Trade.
And in the end, Congress also has to approve.
It can take a while but it is a reliable process.
STOHL: The second one is called direct commercial
sales, and that's where a U.S. vendor or company
engages directly with a foreign client on
a sale.
That client could be a government, it could
be a military, it could be a police force,
it could be any number of private entities.
That is licensed by the Department of State,
but that deal is negotiated by the industry
and the client.
So it's a very different sort of system.
Now, there's still an inter agency review
process of those sales as well to be able
to get a license from the State Department.
SIERRA: Lockheed Martin, which sits at the
top of commercial arms sales, sold over $67
billion dollars worth of weapons in 2021.
In fact, they were the sole contractor for
the largest foreign deal of the year - a $6.9
billion dollar heavy hitter that offered four
combat ships and naval equipment to Greece.
Direct commercial sales still need an export
license and congressional approval, but they
are popular due to the shorter review time.
STOHL: And then the final sort of category,
I'm just going to call U.S. security assistance,
where the U.S. provides defense articles or
services through aid that's funded by the
U.S. taxpayer, but that goes to a foreign
government.
So we hear a lot about that in the context
of Ukraine, for example.
When we hear about drawdowns from U.S. stockpiles,
there are things called excess defense articles.
There's many different programs that cover
this range of security assistance, which is
really an aid based program versus a, I'm
paying you to purchase a particular item.
SIERRA: Regardless of which type of sale the
U.S. engages in, there’s a lot going on
besides profits for arms manufacturers.
The sales provide an economic benefit for
the U.S. military too.
Christa ALMONTE: Taxpayers don't pay for weapons
that go abroad, but they do pay for weapons
that come to our own forces.
SIERRA: This is Captain Christa Almonte.
She is a foreign area officer for the U.S.
Navy.
She is also a visiting fellow here at the
Council, focusing on defense, security and
intelligence.
ALMONTE: If we, say, for example, we put an
order in for 10 helicopters with a U.S. industry.
Five of those are going to go overseas, but
five are going to go to our armed forces,
and we get those cheaper because we basically
bought them by the dozen instead of just the
six that we needed.
That's an actual benefit to us that taxpayers
can feel.
And remember, foreign military sales is, by
no means, limited to arms.
It can be desalinization kits.
It can be flashlights.
It can be night vision goggles.
It can be Jeeps.
It can be just about anything.
SIERRA: Amazing that sales work the same way,
whether you're buying an avocado or a weapon,
that if you buy in bulk you get a good deal.
ALMONTE: Exactly.
ALMONTE: But there's also another side to
it.
Every time a company makes a helicopter or
a Jeep for another country, they do have that
follow-on technical support.
That means it keeps the line open - production
line open over the years.
The United States may have that Jeep, but
we don't need the maintenance on it as much.
We do better upkeep, we already have more
spare parts.
And so we would not, ourselves, be keeping
the production line open.
But because we are still selling it to other
countries, it does keep it open.
It keeps that manufacturer in business.
Whether it's a mom-and-pop manufacturer or
it's a Lockheed Martin and a Boeing of America,
it keeps it open.
That's important because 10 years, 20 years
from now, we may need those spare parts and
if we haven't been selling, then there's been
no reason to keep the production line open.
And frankly, we can't find spare parts to
our own equipment and companies will not necessarily
open the production line back up for us.
They are selling other things and they're
not going to reopen when it's not beneficial
to their own bottom line as well.
SIERRA: Because the U.S. relies on private
industry to arm its large military, it needs
those companies to thrive in the periods between
U.S. purchases.
The argument goes that foreign sales allow
companies to keep operating - and developing
new weapons- so that they’re ready the next
time the U.S. needs something new.
SIERRA: Is there also a benefit that our allies
have the same technology as us?
You know, is it more secure?
ALMONTE: It is.
So there's a few different reasons why technology
from the United States, it's much better for
us to operate with our own technology.
Number one we understand it, it can talk to
itself.
If someone gets a piece of equipment from,
let's just say a European country or from
China, they don't necessarily interoperate
and we can literally sail right past each
other, or fly right past each other, and not
be able to have secure communications.
That's not helpful if you're trying to do
an operation or an exercise and you don't
want people to know the details of it, other
than those you're operating with.
SIERRA: OK, so we understand how foreign arms
sales happen.
But what about why?
Beyond the economic benefits, why does the
U.S. sell weapons to countries all over the
world?
ALMONTE: The simple answer is, U.S. weapon
sales and security assistance programs build
security partnerships among partner nations,
among allies, and with those nations that
are ready and willing but not quite able in
some aspect to advance national security objectives
that are similar to our own here in the U.S.
When we enable partners, we essentially multiply
the forces that we have to answer a call for
a defense, or security, or humanitarian assistance.
We give them the ability to do for themselves.
So we don't have to send our own forces around
the globe quite so often.
And it is a foreign policy tool.
You can see in the news today, President Biden
is again reviewing sales agreements already
signed by his predecessors with Saudi Arabia
as a result of the OPEC agreement to decrease
the oil production, and that was, of course,
largely Saudi Arabia and Russia.
So it is a tool that the president has at
his disposal to sway governments one way or
the other.
If a country does something that we weren't
expecting them to do when we agreed to the
contract, then we certainly have the ability
to put that on hold.
STOHL: Arms transfers are seen by the policy
establishment as contributing to several overarching
national security and foreign policy aims.
And I think the first one is really very obvious
and the most concrete, easiest for us to wrap
our head around, which is we're contributing
to the military capability and capacities
of foreign partners.
So they may be addressing shared security
threats.
Maybe we want to improve military interoperability.
Maybe we want to provide them weapons for
their own self-defense.
It's a very straightforward reason.
But the results are particularly uneven, particularly
over the last few decades.
We also may engage, and when I say we, I mean
the United States, may often engage in arms
transfers as a means to develop access and
influence with a foreign partner.
So that would include things like foreign
basing or over flight rights, or allow the
U.S. military to conduct activities in a foreign
country and to really build a defense relationship.
Now, I should add that influence is really,
really difficult to quantify.
Much of the U.S. arms trade sort of rests
on the assumption that consistent security
cooperation with a foreign partner helps build
U.S. influence.
I think in reality the impact is really difficult
to measure.
And we can look at lots of anecdotal episodes
suggesting that the efficacy of security cooperation
in shaping the behavior of a foreign partner
to act in a way that the U.S. wants it to
act is really questionable.
SIERRA: Are there good examples from history
when the U.S. has regretted providing or selling
arms?
HARTUNG: If you look at when the Soviet Union
invaded Afghanistan at the end of the '70s,
the US strategy was to arm the Mujahideen
- some of the extremist groups that were helping
drive the Soviets back.
And some of those players went on to become
part of the base of al-Qaeda.
Osama bin Laden was part of the supply chain
for that pushback against the Soviets.
So you had this blow back or what I call the
boomerang effect, where you sell arms for
one reason and they come back to be used against
you in another context.
Hillary Clinton: We were just so happy to
see the Soviet Union fall and we thought ‘okay
fine, we’re okay now.
Things are going to be so much better.’
Now, you look back, the people we’re fighting
today, we were supporting in the fight against
the Soviets.
HARTUNG: In Iraq, because of ISIS, and even
before that because of corruption, many of
the US weapons ended up in the hands of anti
US forces that had been supplied to the Iraqi
government.
Some were lost in Yemen.
There's various other places where this has
happened.
So it's like once you sell these arms, you
... And they will last for decades.
They're usable for long periods of time.
Politics will change, the chaos of war.
For various reasons, they can end up on the
wrong side relative to US interests and so
that's a big concern.
STOHL: I think our security cooperation history
is sort of replete with examples of transfers
that in retrospect, were deeply regrettable.
I mean, you can go all the way back to the
Arms For Hostages deal that eventually became
known as the Iran Contra Affair.
You can think about security forces that would
use them in violation of human rights or international
humanitarian law.
But we can go back to many, many other cases
throughout history where we know U.S. arms
have been used in contravention of sort of
U.S. interests and U.S. values.
And that's sort of the problem.
When your values don't align with the recipient
country and you can't influence their behavior,
often you see that mismatch.
SIERRA: Many agree with Rachel that the U.S.
should consider selling fewer weapons to countries
that don’t share U.S. values: particularly
authoritarian countries.
But in some administrations, officials saw
that as yielding the field and competitive
balance to arms rivals like Russia and China.
STOHL: I don't want to make the case that
all arm sales are bad.
I certainly don't believe that.
I think there are cases where we've seen necessary
or positive outcomes.
I think Ukraine right now is a very good example
of where effective U.S. security cooperation
in the short term, and I want to say we don't
know what's going to happen with these weapons
in the long term, but for right now, we understand
that short term need to provide those weapons.
There are lots of others.
We can go back to U.S. military cooperation
with Europe after World War II and sort of
how our Western allies have rebuilt their
militaries.
And we don't generally have sort of negative
views of arms transfers to our NATO allies.
Those are positive relationships.
I think the big sort of overall problem is
when we use security cooperation as a bandaid
for a short term crisis, but we don't consider
long term strategic thinking about desired
outcome and potential impacts, that's where
we have that disconnect.
SIERRA: For years, this type of thinking was
not very common in the U.S. government - but
there is evidence that some of that might
be changing.
STOHL: In the last decade, we've really seen
the political salience of arms transfers and
responsible security cooperation grow substantially,
and particularly among lawmakers.
I mean, I've had more conversations about
the arms trade in the last decade than probably
the 15, 20 years before.
People just are aware whether we're talking
about Saudi Arabia and the war in Yemen, whether
we're talking about Ukraine, Afghanistan,
Iraq, it's just a more politically salient
topic.
And we're seeing more and more members of
Congress raise concerns about particular arms
transfers.
Rand Paul: Saudi Arabia’s air and naval
blockade of Yemen has led to thousands and
thousands of deaths in Yemen from lack of
food and medicine.
The U.S. should end all arms sales to the
Saudis until they end their blockade of Yemen.
Elizabeth Warren: We need to ask ourselves
if the benefits of this relationship with
Saudi Arabia is worth the costs if this kind
of behavior continues.
Chris Murphy: Every single one of those bombs
is stamped with made in the USA, and Yemenis
know this.
They don’t see this as a Saudi bombing campaign,
they see this as an American bombing campaign.
STOHL: And we've even seen legislation around
arms transfers in order to strengthen the
guardrails that are meant to avert risky or
damaging U.S. arms transfers.
And I think there was a joint resolution of
disapproval passed in 2019, and then lots
of bills just in the last three years since
that were aimed at limiting U.S. military
cooperation with Saudi Arabia and other human
rights abusers.
They did not have a veto proof majority, which
is why they did not pass.
But it was really notable that for the first
time you had bipartisan support to actually
disapprove of an arms transfer.
There's lots of things Congress can do to
flip the script a little bit and have to approve
arms transfers rather than only being allowed
to vote to disapprove them.
But it's a really interesting time, I think,
for Congress to re-engage in this conversation.
SIERRA: Why are you seeing this now?
STOHL: I think that we really have seen this
in the aftermath of what's happened with Saudi
Arabia, both with their perpetuation of the
war in Yemen with the killing of Jamal Khashoggi.
I think there's just more light being shed
on who our partners are and the behaviors
that they undertake.
And I think also there's been a question of
how has the U.S. been able to influence the
behavior of Saudi Arabia through its arms
transfer relationship?
And I think the most recent OPEC production
cut is a really great example because it's
a pretty fairly blunt rejection of the longstanding
oil for guns bargain that has defined the
U.S. Saudi relationship.
And so I think there's just more attention
being paid to are we actually able to influence
the behavior of the recipients of these arms?
And the answer is overwhelmingly time and
time again, no.
And so I think people are questioning on that
sort of ethical and moral ground.
I mean, when you see a school bus of children
killed by a U.S. weapon that was never intended
to target civilians, you have to ask yourself
questions like is this really where we want
to be involved?
And I think members of Congress are finally
asking those questions.
SIERRA: Oversight before a sale is one thing,
but these sales also create ongoing partnerships,
not least because of the need for parts and
maintenance.
As such, the U.S. often conducts oversight
after a sale.
But experts do disagree on how effective this
oversight ultimately is.
ALMONTE: Depending upon the case, the ongoing
relationship can last years.
It can last a lot longer than the initial
case, for example.
When I was the Security Assistance Officer
in Bahrain, one of my duties was what we call,
end-use monitoring.
So, an item is delivered to a country and
they have it in use.
They have it in their garrison, they're using
it in defense of whatever it is, let's say
night vision goggles, for example.
I then had to go and account for all of these
items to make sure the country had not transferred
them anywhere else.
I literally had to go find the bases where
I knew they were keeping the material and
I had a list with the serial numbers and the
amounts and quantities and they would lay
out 50, or 100, or 150 of these items and
I would check off one serial number at a time.
I would take occasionally another American
with me from the embassy to do it because
it really is a comprehensive assessment.
I couldn't have one of the host nation men
do it because it's about American eyes on
these items to make sure they are where they
are said they are, and they're being used
for what they promised they would be used
for.
SIERRA: Wow.
And that's an ongoing process.
ALMONTE: It's absolutely ongoing.
It's a cyclical process and depending upon
the equipment it can happen every year.
STOHL: So some systems are easier to track
than others.
Obviously we think about using small arms
as an example.
There's a serial number on that gun, and you
can track it from point A to point B to point
C. Other systems also have identifying numbers
and characteristics that allow you to track
them and our end use monitoring very much
looks like, "Okay, does this serial number
or this box match what it says on this piece
of paper that we actually provided?
Is it where we said it would be?"
That does happen.
What becomes harder is who is utilizing that
system.
We may say, this can go to this unit or for
this purpose, but once it gets across the
water or the land, it's difficult to keep
track of what is where.
And we've seen particularly in conflict zones.
So you think Afghanistan, Iraq, or even Ukraine
at the moment, on just recent examples, it's
very difficult to say in the moment, this
is where all of those systems are that we
have provided.
Some systems are easier to do that with than
others.
It's very hard to quickly and quietly move
a tank or an aircraft, but it's a lot easier
when you're talking about small arms and light
weapons.
So your risks are very different as well.
SIERRA: I was going to ask, is this a structural
issue, like we just don't have the amount
of people that we need and the technology
we need to track these weapons when they get
to another country?
Or is it that we just don't have the will
because we don't view it as a huge problem?
HARTUNG: I think it's a combination of the
two.
We definitely need more resources for end
use monitoring, but I think because there's
a bias towards selling, there's less interest
perhaps in keeping track of how the weapons
are used in a systematic way.
So I think the two sort of go together.
There's a resource issue, and there's an issue
of political strategic priorities that come
into play.
SIERRA: Have we ever gone and been like, Okay,
well, you broke our deal, and we are demanding
these back, or we're gonna go get them back?
Is that sort of just not on the table, like
as an option?
STOHL: So we don't usually say, "Can we have
those back?"
There’s a couple exceptions.
For example, the United States provided stinger
missiles to Afghanistan in the late 70s, and
they caused a lot of problems for U.S. forces
even decades later.
And so in the early 2000s, the United States
actually engaged in a buyback program for
what's called MANPADS, man-portable air-defense
systems, and has sort of bought those back.
That's a really hard thing to do.
It's not something the U.S. government engages
in all that regularly.
That said, we have other tools in our toolbox
to be able to stop sales if they are particularly
problematic.
If they are used in ways that are in contravention
with the end user agreement, if they are used
to commit human rights violations or if they're
used in conflict that were not sort of the
purpose of that sale.
So we can stop sales.
We don't send everything all at once.
We may not grant future licenses.
So there can be some sort of punitive measures
that are taken if a government or an end user
does not act responsibly.
SIERRA: We wanted to know what it was like
seeing and handling this process on the ground,
and, as she said before, Christa has had experience
in the field when it comes to oversight.
SIERRA: You did this firsthand, you were on
the ground, you talked about counting serial
numbers.
Ultimately this is a business, a lethal business.
I wonder if you could speak a little bit to
how it's felt for you in this process.
ALMONTE: You have to see this from both ways.
There was a book that was written by Andrew
Feinstein called Shadow World.
I'm guessing by the title, you can probably
guess how he felt about arms trade, but it
was called Shadow World and the Global Arms
Trade.
Essentially, it was an exposé, and it was
fantastically written.
And if you've read it and don't have any experience
in the arms trade, you would say, "My God,
what are we doing around the world?"
But you have to look at what I have already
enumerated, and that is the many, many, many
methods we use to ensure things like what
are covered in that book do not happen today.
That the arms trade of years ago doesn't happen
today.
And that's how I tried to look at it.
When I was in Bahrain, a great ally of ours,
thousands upon thousands of American soldiers
and sailors passed through there over the
years, including me.
I've been stationed there three different
times.
They're in no danger of being overthrown.
They're never going to turn a weapon on us.
But I went over as a fresh young officer,
and I saw these operations and I spoke to
their military, and I literally carried weapons
to be delivered in the back of my vehicle
to their bases, and I delivered them in person.
Over the serial numbers they would read off
and I would read off and we would sign the
bottom saying, "Yep, you now have control
of this weapon."
It crossed my mind more than once a day, I
would say, that these weapons have been used
against us in the past.
Again, my husband and my husband's brother,
a lot of my friends have been deployed into
Iraq and Afghanistan over the years.
And it's something you must, all of America
that's involved in this process must keep
that in the back of their mind.
If we don't, then we will overlook something
in the process and we will sell to the wrong
person at the wrong time.
So if we are not questioning ourselves with
each and every sale, we are doing something
wrong, and that's how I felt about it.
I read Feinstein's book because, even though
I was in the arms business, I wanted to understand
where we could go wrong, to avoid going wrong.
SIERRA: I can't help but think about this
in very simple terms.
If you give a neighbor a gun to defend themselves
or you sell it to them, you can't really control
how they choose to use it.
There will always be a risk that one day it
could be used for evil.
I think that's how a lot of people feel about
the U.S. arms trade, that in the end it will
always fuel death.
So, what thoughts do you have about the morality
of the arms trade?
HARTUNG: There's many - too many cases of
arming repressive regimes that are causing
huge humanitarian suffering.
And so in that case, when it's being done
knowing that that's going to be the result,
I think it's immoral.
I think it shouldn't happen.
You know, if we focused in on the most problematic
sales and made it harder for those to happen,
the world would be a much better place, the
United States would be safer, many fewer people
would be suffering.
And because it's not the whole trade that's
at issue, some of these arguments about the
economics of it a little bit fall by the wayside.
I mean, it's not most advocates of arms transfer
control are not saying shut down the whole
arms trade.
They're saying, let's not sell to these repressive
regimes.
Let's take a look at how the weapons are being
used.
All those things can be done and they'll affect
a portion of the trade, but not the entire
trade.
So I think some distinctions have to be made,
but there certainly is an element where you
see, either an immoral or amoral approach
that has devastating human consequences.
STOHL: I wish I saw the world in a more sort
of black and white way, but I don't actually
take a principled position on whether arms
transfers are inherently good or inherently
bad.
I think they serve a purpose.
The problem is, and sort of where I am concerned
is they all too often take place sort of irresponsibly
or unaccountably or without transparency.
That's where I see the challenge.
And I think the other challenge for me is
that they're often seen as a tool, a first
resort, rather than what are our other opportunities?
Are there diplomatic solutions?
And if we decide, nope, this is the way to
go, are we putting in place measures to mitigate
any risks that we have identified in sort
of our deep thinking about this particular
sale?
So I see there are some really serious challenges
and problems within the current U.S. security
cooperation enterprise.
And those problems are going to continue to
impact the lives of people all over the world.
In some cases, we've seen blow back from those
weapons against U.S. forces, but also against
U.S. interests.
And so I think we have to, again, not just
look at the short term, but think about those
medium and long term consequences.
And I think if we are going to continue to
sell weapons for whatever reason, we need
to do so in an incredibly responsible and
accountable and transparent way.
And all transfers should really reflect our
morals, our values, our understanding of decades
of best practice, and in ways that we know
are going to contribute to long term interests
and outcomes.
These are not like, "We'll sell them and see
what happens."
We really need to be thoughtful about how
we utilize arms transfers in our foreign policy
and national security goals.
SIERRA: For resources used in this episode
and more information, visit CFR.org/whyitmatters
and take a look at the show notes.
This time, we tried something new, and it’s
super cool.
Our data visualization colleague, Will Merrow,
designed a series of maps and charts to help
you understand how the U.S. arms trade is
touching every corner of the world.
Check them out.
If you ever have any questions or suggestions
or just want to chat, email us at whyitmatters@cfr.org.
You can subscribe to the show on Apple Podcasts,
Spotify, Stitcher, or wherever you get your
audio.
If you have the time and love the show you
could leave us a review - it helps us get
noticed, and we just love to read them.
Why It Matters is a production of the Council
on Foreign Relations.
The show is produced by Asher Ross and me,
Gabrielle Sierra.
Our sound designer is Markus Zakaria.
Our associate podcast producer is Molly McAnany.
Our intern this semester is Mormei Zanke.
Robert McMahon is our Managing Editor, and
Doug Halsey is our Chief Digital Officer.
Extra help for this episode was provided by
Jonathan Masters and Claire Klobucista.
Our theme music is composed by Ceiri Torjussen.
We’d also like to thank Richard Haass, Jeff
Reinke and our co-creator Jeremy Sherlick.
For Why It Matters, this is Gabrielle Sierra
signing off.
See you around!